un immeuble abandonné sur trois étages
en plein centre ville de besançon
le cas n'est pas rare les agents
immobiliers parle de veron est ce le
reflet du parc de logements dans la
ville pas vraiment selon l'insee le taux
de vacance qui indique les logements
vides dans l'agglomération de besançon
et de 6% seulement mieux que dijon
calculé à 7%
beaucoup mieux que la moyenne régionale
à 10%
un bon résultat qui cache une surprise
l'hyper centre de besançon n'est pas au
mieux de sa forme
l'habitant aux siens à reculer on a eu
une arrivée de logements neufs et
notamment loi de défiscalisation sur
besançon dont qui ont fait du bien sur
l'état général du parc locatif bisontins
et ça engendre donc de la vacance
locative pour les appartements qui ont
pas suivi c'est à dire les appartements
où les propriétaires n'ont pas voulu
faire de travaux ceux là vont souffrir
de vacance locative sur la période
2010-2015 la vacance dans le
centre-ville aurait augmenté de 40%
toujours selon l'insee
les agents immobiliers l'expliquent
facilement la fermeture de l'hôpital
saint jacques et de l'ancienne fac de
médecine ont pesé dans la balance
la faculté de médecine premier cycle qui
il est allé me crée donc hauts du chazal
donc ses environs médecine pharmacie
c'est de l'ordre de deux à trois mille
élèves
c'est l'hôpital saint-jacques e rep ou
mondon qui est à l'émigré également donc
à l'hôpital donc c'est pareil environ
2000 personnes
donc automatiquement la personne c'est
notre travail plus au centre ville eh
bien elle trouve peut-être moins
d'intérêt à y habiter
quelles conséquences pour les locataires
ou les futurs acheteurs
la réponse des professionnels est plutôt
engageante nous ça nous oblige à faire
pression auprès des propriétaires qui
n'ont pas pris conscience que on loue
plus aussi chère qu'avant est dans le
même état qu'auparavant
donc il arrive qu'on fasse faire des
travaux et que
on est deux manières corollaire une
baisse du loyer donc ça surprend à
surprendre propriétaire le logement neuf
à besançon va s'étoffer comme ici dans
le futur quartier vauban avec 800
logements prévus ce projet devrait faire
baisser un peu plus encore les prix de
l'ancien